اثنان من المنبوذين الدوليين يتحولان إلى
بعضهما البعض عندما لم يبق سوى عدد قليل من الحلفاء الآخرين، حيث
تبسط روسيا السجادة الحمراء
حرفيًا لجذب الدكتاتور الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ أون الذي أمسك بعد ذلك
بيد الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين لمدة
40 ثانية كاملة عند وصوله اليوم
وقال "وأنا"  نقلاً عنه الآن أنه
سيقف دائمًا مع روسيا.
تضمنت هذه الزيارة جولة في
منشأة إطلاق الصواريخ الروسية وعشاء عقاري لمدة خمس ساعات
من المفاوضات وانتهت
بدعوة كيم بوتين إلى بيونغ يانغ لكن بوتين كان
يأمل في صفقة أسلحة كبيرة لمساعدة
إمداداته وإعادة الإمداد.  قواته
الموجودة في أوكرانيا في مقابل قيل لنا
إنه سيعد بمساعدة
برنامج الفضاء الكوري الشمالي المتعثر. الانضمام
إلي الآن الليلة مجاني زكريا مضيف
فريد زكريا نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS) ومجاني أعني أنني
أتساءل فقط أنك تعرف رؤية هذين الاثنين
معزولين للغاية  القادة يشربون نخب اللحوم كما
فعل كيم مع كفاح بوتين المقدس
ضد الغرب كما أسماه ما مدى
خطورة تعتقد أن هذا العصر الجديد من
العلاقات بين روسيا وكوريا الشمالية
حسنًا، إنه ليس خطيرًا
بمعنى أنه علامة ضعف أه
فلاديمير بوتين  يسعى للحصول على القش،
فهو يتواصل مع عدد قليل من الأشخاص في
النظام الدولي الذين يرغبون في
رؤيتهم معه، لكنه لم يتمكن من الذهاب
إلى القمة البريطانية في جنوب إفريقيا
خوفًا من أن يتم القبض عليه من قبل
حكومة جنوب إفريقيا بناءً على
مذكرة اعتقال دولية.  لذا فهو نعم، كما تعلم أنه في
حالة أسوأ بكثير مما كان عليه،
كوريا الشمالية هي الحليف الأخير الذي
تريده في العالم، هناك
دولة فقيرة متخلفة لديهم
برنامج نووي صغير، لذا فهي ليست في الحقيقة
علامة على القوة، إنها علامة على القوة.  علامة على أن بوتين
هو الذي تعرفه على الجانب الآخر،
حلفاء أوكرانيا عددهم 50 60 من
أغنى الدول في
العالم ولكن هاتين دولتين مفسدتين
وأعني بذلك أنهما
دولتان في الأساس أه تعيشان
وتزدهران في تعطيل
النظام الدولي بشأن التسبب في نوايا التسبب في
عدم الاستقرار وبهذا المعنى إذا
اتحد الاثنان معًا بشكل أكثر إحكامًا مما
كانا عليه في الماضي أه أه
يمكن أن تعلم أنه يمكنك أن تتخيل أنه
يسبب نوعًا من المشاكل
الطموحات النووية لكوريا الشمالية  قد تنمو أه
قد تكتسب بعض تقنيات الأسلحة التي
لم تمتلكها من قبل ولكن أه كما تعلم
في الغالب أعتقد أن بوتين يفعل ذلك
لأنه لا يوجد الكثير من الحلفاء
يمكنك انتزاعهم أنت تعرف أنه
يستطيع تبادل المجاملات مع هؤلاء
أيام ناهيك عن تبادل أي نوع من
التعاملات التجارية أو العسكرية ذات المغزى، نعم وبشكل منفصل، كما تعلمون، نظرًا لأن
الولايات المتحدة تنظر إلى هذا، فمن الواضح أن
هذا شيء يراقبونه عن
كثب في هذه القمة ولكن بالحديث عن
القيادة هنا في الجيش، أعني أن
الجنرال مارك ميلي سيذهب
ستتنحى قريبًا عن منصب رئيس
هيئة الأركان المشتركة في
نهاية الشهر وجلست وأجريت
مقابلة معه وتحدثت عن
شيء ركزنا عليه كثيرًا هنا
وهو هذه الادعاءات حول هذه
الوثيقة التي كان لدى ترامب  معه،
يُزعم أن هذه الخطط لمهاجمة إيران
هي وثيقة سرية كان ترامب
يلوح بها أمام الأشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم تصاريح أمنية، ومن
الواضح أنها جزء من تحقيق كبير
بشأن ترامب الآن، وهذا ما
أخبرك به الجنرال ميلي عن ذلك
المزعوم  الوثيقة
هناك اتهام محدد عنك
وجهه رئيس أركان الرئيس السابق
مارك ميدوز أه وهو يقول أن هناك
هذه المذكرة المكونة من أربع صفحات أه
خطة الهجوم للهجوم على الولايات المتحدة
لمهاجمة العراق إيران ترامب نفسه
تحدث عن هذا هذا هو
الوثيقة السرية الشهيرة التي كان يلوح
بها لكن ميدوز يوجه الاتهام
بأنك كنت تضغط على الرئيس ترامب
لمهاجمة إيران. هناك تقارير أخرى
تقول في الواقع أن ترامب هو الذي كان
يضغط عليك، ما هو
البيان الدقيق هنا،
خائف جدًا من النظر إليه  "سيكون من
غير المناسب جدًا بالنسبة لي أن أعلق على
أي شيء يخضع لتحقيق فيدرالي حالي،
لذا لن أفعل ذلك ولكن دعني
أقول هذا كرئيس أو أي
عضو في هيئة الأركان المشتركة، مهمتنا هي
تقديم المشورة التي لدينا خطط لها  جميع
أنواع الأشياء وعندما نقدم
النصائح عادة ما نقول مسار العمل،
واحد أو اثنين أو ثلاثة نتحدث عن التكاليف
والمخاطر ونقدم
توصيات ويمكنني أن أؤكد لك
أنه لن تفعل ذلك ولو لمرة واحدة إذا
أوصيت بمهاجمة إيران  من هذا الرد على ريد،
اعتقدت أنه كان ملفتًا للنظر في الواقع،
اعتقدت أنه ذهب إلى ما هو أبعد قليلاً مما
قاله إنه سيذهب، كما تعلم أنه قال
أنني لن أعلق على هذا
ولكن من الواضح أن ذلك أزعجه بدرجة كافية
أنه قرر التعليق على ذلك
على أي حال وبقدر ما أستطيع أن أقول
كان ذلك نهائيًا جدًا أه لقد
ادعى ترامب مرارًا وتكرارًا وكما تقول في
تلك المحادثات التي أجراها مع
أه مع أشخاص ليس لديهم أي فصل
لا تعرفه أه نفقات أمنية  أه أن
هيئة الأركان المشتركة التي يضطهده ميلي بشكل خاص
للهجوم على أن هذه كانت
خطة هجوم بالنسبة لك وليس مارك ميدوز
يكتب ذلك في مقدمة
مذكراته ويعطيها مكانة مرموقة
وهو البيان الافتتاحي لرئيس
أركان الرئيس
و  يقول ميلي بشكل قاطع أن هذا
لم يحدث أه من الجدير بالذكر أنه على
حق أه ميلي على حق عندما
يقول أن لديهم خطط هجومية لكل
شيء أه الولايات المتحدة
لديها حقًا خطط كما تعلم لجميع أنواع
الطوارئ لكنه كان
حاسمًا جدًا أنه لم يفعل  لم
أقترح أبدًا أن تقوم الولايات المتحدة
بشن غزو لإيران
في الخارج